>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR SPEED
19 WHERE OUR NEWS EXPERTS
COMPETE TO SEE WHO IS THE BEST
AT RECALLING THE EVENTS WE COVER
JUST THIS WEEK.
WE HAVE OUR CONTESTANTS,
GRIFF JENKINS, WHO YOU CAN SEE
HAS BEEN GRAVELY INJURED IN THE
PURSUIT OF HIS DUTY.
I HOPE YOU ARE OKAY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU BOTH.
I'M HOSTING FROM AN UNDISCLOSED
LOCATION WITH THE JUDGE IS
PRESENT.
SO IF THERE IS ANY QUESTION AT
ALL, THEY ARE RIGHT HERE OUTSIDE
OF THIS CAMERA SHOT TO ADVISE
ME.
YOU KNOW THE RULES, BUT FOR OUR
VIEWERS AT HOME WHO MAY NOT
REMEMBER THEM, THERE ARE THESE
HANDSOME BUZZERS.
I ASKED THE QUESTION IN THE
FIRST ONE TO BUZZ IN GET TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
EVERY CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH
ONE POINT AND IT DETRACTS FROM
YOUR POINTS AS THE TOTAL.
ARE YOU READY?
>> LET'S GO.
>> Tucker: WHICH SWEDISH POP
GROUP ANNOUNCED THEY ARE GETTING
BACK TOGETHER AFTER 35 YEARS TO
MAKE NEW MUSIC, BUT THEY ARE
UNSURE WHETHER THEIR SONGS ARE
ANY GOOD?
>> ABBA.
>> Tucker: DID THE SWEDISH
GROUP GIVE IT AWAY?
LET'S CHECK THE TAPE.
>> ABBA IS MAKING A COMEBACK.
♪ ♪
THE SWEDISH BAND ANNOUNCED THEIR
DECISION TO RELEASE NEW SONGS
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       T
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       U
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       R
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       A
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       T
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       R
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       3
AND A VIRTUAL TOOL AFTER       5
YEARS.
>> Tucker: I LOVE THAT.
GOOD JOB.
GRIFF IS UP ONE.
QUESTION NUMBER TWO, MULTIPLE
CHOICE.
HILLARY CLINTON FOUND YET
ANOTHER GROUP TO BLAME FOR HER
LOSS AND THE 2016 ELECTION.
WHICH GROUP IS EIGHT.
A, THE SOCIALISTS.
B, THE VEGANS.
OR C, THE SATANIC TEMPLE.
>> THOSE ARE GOOD CHOICES.
>> Tucker: WHICH GROUP IS
HILLARY BLAMING?
>> I THINK SHE'S BLAMING THE
SOCIALISTS.
>> Tucker: LET'S SEE IF YOU
ARE RIGHT.
>> IF YOU ARE IN THE IOWA
CAUCUSES AND 41% OF DEMOCRATS
ARE SOCIALISTS OR SELF-DESCRIBED
SOCIALISTS, AND I'M AFTER YOU,
AND CAPITALISTS, AND I SAY YES,
THAT PROBABLY GETS LOST IN, OH,
MY GOSH, SHE'S A CAPITALIST.
>> Tucker: SHE IS DEFINITELY A
CAPITALIST, THAT'S FOR SURE.
NICE JOB.
IT'S 1-1.
YOU VERSUS THE INJURED
QUESTION THREE.
GEORGE W. BUSH WAS MAKING HIS
FAREWELL VISIT TO IRAQ WHEN A
MAN, YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS, TOOK
OFF HIS SHOES AND THREW THEM AT
PRESIDENT BUSH.
THE MAN WHO THREW HIS SHOES IS
NOW EMBARKING ON A BRAND-NEW
CAREER.
WHAT IS IT?
SPEECH >> WAY I COULD GUESS
SPEECH >> WAY I COULD GUESA
SPEECH >> WAY I COULD GUES
SPEECH >> WAY I COULD GUESH
SPEECH >> WAY I COULD GUEST
ONE.
>> Tucker: YOU COULD HIT THE
BUZZER BUT YOU GUESS.
A NEW CAREER FOR THE SHOE
THROWER?
>> I'M GOING TO GUESS HE IS
GOING TO BE LIKE A P/E COACH, OR
BASEBALL OR LITTLE LEAGUE.
SOMETHING WHERE HE HAS TO THROW
THINGS, WITH CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: BASEBALL COACH,
LITTLE LEAGUE, SOMETHING FROM
THE SPORTING WORLD WHERE YOU
HAVE TO THROW THINGS.
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> HE IS A MAN WHO TOOK NINE
MONTHS IN PRISON FOR DECIDING ON
GEORGE BUSH'S FAREWELL TOUR TO
PICK UP HIS SHOES OFF HIS FEET
AND THROW THEM AT THE PRESIDENT.
HE IS NOW GOING TO BE RUNNING
FOR OFFICE.
IN CASE YOU WERE WONDERING, HE'S